well game two and getting the start here
this afternoon is going to be
left-hander ryan yarbrough left-handed
thrower against the right-handed batting
boba chef in 2-2 from the slow roller to
the right side waiting for it now
wendell he picks it up throws onto choi
and it took seven pitches but there is
out number one and now
five fly ball into left to gone slow
grounded right to anomalously short into
his left
will toss off balance to first inside to
retire guerrero
shoemaker has pitched well against tampa
bay but he hasn't faced them since 2017.
he's done a heck of a job of staying
ready to pitch this season troy steps
into the box and ready to go here in the
bottom of the first
the chopper towards first nice easy
bounce for travis shaw one pitch one
down designated hitter yoshi tsutsugo
first pitch swinging and he's popped it
up shallow center the shet there will
make the catch a very big second down
for man shoemaker joey wendell and he
swings and he lines the ball caught at
third base by espinal his first
defensive challenge comes right to him
on a drawn in infield he's got out
number three to carry this game
scoreless through the first inning of
play
two up two down scoreless in the second
william thomas the battle 2-2
swinging up high pop-up around home
plate back pedaling in front of the dish
there's reese maguire in fair territory
a two-handed squeeze and a tumble but
he'll hold on with the ball in the
leather one two three four match
shoemakers no score here in the top of
the third
outfield shallow in the pitch he struck
him out as espinal could not
catch up to that cutter and we're two
out to the bases empty here in the third
we go to the top of the order in both
the shed
here's brandon lau
their strike three called beautiful
splinter by matt shoemaker one two three
inning for shoemaker he's retired eight
straight annual margot is over one of
the ball game two maker deals and a
swing and a miss great sweeping slider
there to get margo second strike out of
the afternoon for shoemaker
boy he can do so many different things
with the baseball and this sweeping
breaking ball watch how it breaks down
in the way
just continues to break it starts out on
plate breaks all the way into the others
batter's box embargo is pulled badly on
that big breaking ball two quick house
here at the bottom of the fifth here's
willy adams
[Applause]
got him
another good inning for matt shoemaker
who is dealing today five scoreless
hittings
richie sends it into center
coming on to make the catch caremeyer
with a little slide to boot and that
retires the side
no runs two hits and two men left aboard
slides forward and makes the catch blue
jays leave two to the end of five and a
half still toronto in the race scoreless
so the runner at first we go to the top
side of the order and g-man choi is the
hitter
fly ball toward left center field richik
on the move he can't get there one hop
into the wall
rosso hitting third on the way to the
plate the throw will not be in time on
the double by joy and the rays grab a
one nothing lead opposite way into
left-center field
off the bat of g-man joy
well you you were looking for that
breakthrough and so you get rosso out
there on the base pass with a little bit
more speed a two-seam fastball that
stays middle of the plate up and g-man
choi
driving it with authority left center
field going to clear the outfielders one
hop the wall
give the raise the lead and also set
them up well that's a nice read by
brasso realizing that ball was not going
to be caught
there the battery is yoshi tsutsugo
great play at first shaw from the seat
of his pants will feed shoemaker for the
third out
that'll bring reese maguire to the
looking for their first run there's the
swing and a fly ball hit to deep right
field by reese mcguire it's gone
reese maguire has tied this game his
first hit of the season is a solo shot
in the top of the seventh inning and
it's one one
blue jays and reyes and rhys mcguire
just continues
to hit in the big leagues
far better than he ever did in the
minors
wow
that's seven rows up into the seats in
right adventure under renfro at second
as choi walks and that puts the
potential go ahead run
into scoring position well it's brandon
lau now to face gavilio
and a shot toward right center that ball
is gonna go all the way to the wall
graves will take the lead as renfro
scores joy rounding third on his way to
the plate into third goes loud the rays
take a 3-1 lead
brandon lau found the gap in right
center
and drives in both runs three to one
tampa bay
boy and you wonder right here is charlie
montoya
kicking himself for leaving cabelio out
there to face brandon lau yeah you start
to look and see who
cash had you know maybe to come in as a
pinch hitter but that pitch was left out
over the plate and brandon loud shoots
it out into right center field renfro
making sure it gets down he's gonna
score and then all the way around here
comes g-man
a two-run cushion here
three outs to go
here's gandhi
easy to second-guess oh now ball
has been called
and that's gonna get lau home
from third and the raise will pick up
an additional run that's four to one now
yeah and then that call was definitive
we're gonna have to take a look and see
what camillo did but he doesn't seem to
be putting up much of an argument there
he is get that foot get set i think
there was a start to stop what it looked
like back to back three on assisted to
start this ninth inning and the blue
jays have nobody on down three runs with
two outs well the shot is coming
and a around and a miss and that's gonna
do it raise your winners
[Music]
oliver drake strikes out paul machette
three up three down
kill the blue jays and the
knife heading and the raise with a
three-run eighth
win this one 4-1
with a raise four runs five hits no
errors and four left one eight and oh
and there is the final out